foreign
I am proud and delighted to announce we
have our first guest on the show who
matches the studio perfectly
it's so nice this is the nicest thing
I've heard all day it's a walking good
for you podcast Studio her name is Sarah
Sherman do you like Sarah score do
people call you sir squirm now and
you're like well it's really Sherman I
like well I was always performing a
Sarah scorm and not until the show have
I gone by my brother TV I'm at TV of
course I'm actually missed Swan not many
people know that
so but do you like have this thing where
you're like I need to change my
Instagram to Sarah Sherman because I my
brain I'm very like as soon as I like
found out about you and looked your
Instagram I was like we gotta start
branding is that true because I actually
I haven't really thought about it but
people be people be saying this it's so
much cooler to not and to just let
people be bewildered and confused but
I'm just like how much higher would your
Google searches be if you ever need that
for some kind of butterfly clip campaign
negotiation you know and if someone's
Googling Sarah squirm and that gets a
million uh Googles and then Sarah
Sherman gets a million Googles
where's your leverage you're gonna have
to go to the the butterfly clip company
you're a genius I've literally never
thought about this this is and you're
gonna be like no and they're like well
you got a million Google so you might
and you're like I actually got two
million it's just no one knows my name
oh my God this is ruining my life you're
100 I don't like I don't know I always
thought I was always thinking about it
you're thinking you're thinking like a
businesswoman you're being a girl boss
right now and I am too stupid to
everything like literally the only way
I've been thinking about this is like
conceptually where I'm like I clock into
work because Sarah German and then after
work I take off my hand and then I get
to be Sarah squirm at night
but that's not like a way to think about
my you know yes I mean well then maybe
the move is if I'm gonna put my business
please for that you can have two
businesses going like for the companies
that don't feel Sarah squirm is a match
for them yes maybe Sarah Sherman is
maybe Sarah Sherman's doing the J crew
campaigns in Sarah's squirm is doing the
Bumpits you know the only company that's
ever been like I'm gonna have a lot of
burp say I've been drinking like a lot
of Kombucha so just kombucha kombucha
oh well the only business who's ever
asked me to do like a Business
Partnership around was the um was an
activity close it was um the the
underwear that you could have your
period in
and I was like well that makes sense I
didn't do it but I was like really
cheaper than buying tie-dye yeah thank
you
um did you not do it I did not do it
okay why not I don't need to help them I
don't need it to be helping them yeah
respect free bleeding what you're saying
is it wasn't enough money
I don't even think I have like a mental
issue with responding to emails and like
this is my you're see you're gonna I
think today you're gonna save my life
you were living in Chicago uh it's gonna
sound like I edited that it's I just
changed the subject that fast yeah you
didn't want you didn't want to do it and
then I stuttered to add insult to injury
you went from Long Island to Chicago
you're in Chicago how long how long
eight years wild now I left school there
I went to this Pete's in Chicago
it's too I can't eat that pizza I cannot
eat like that it's fucked up
you can't eat like that it's like nine
inches of fifties
you know how lactose intolerant I am
okay so eating mold you're saying that
eating mold is not good for your gut
bacteria yeah it's not oh my God I'm
obsessed with my stomach right now do
you hear me talk about the way I'm
talking that's all we're talking about
that's all we're talking let's get into
it it's my perspective even about pizza
now is completely changed by my gut
bacteria being wild did you uh you're
dating someone right I'm dating someone
okay good I know I just woke talk about
that in a second but I'm just saying
this is not a first date if you're out
there in the in the field don't maybe
open with the gut bacteria day one
um but so being lactose intolerant is
this is something new Jewish no it's
just something Jewish uh General Judaism
but you've always because everyone is
kind of lactose Intel I mean it's like
no one's really totally I like well do
it what's funny about Jews is that like
the main thing that we love is the thing
that betrays us so like the thing that
we love the most is whipped cream cheese
and like white fish Herring cream sauce
whatever and that's like the thing all
Jews can't eat yeah but that's the thing
we love the most yeah but if you ate it
a lot you wouldn't like it as much no I
like so I had like full-blown diarrhea
for like the first 24 years of my life
and I was like you know maybe I should
cut out the cream cheese and then it was
actually saved my life have you done
none uh dairy cream cheese
a little bit of jelly oh fuck out of
here have you been to courage Bagels oh
it is the best bagel I've never been I
went yesterday and it was closed no you
gotta wait in line for two and a half
hours it's worth it but like who am I in
line with we're talking a lot of 25 year
old for lack of a better term
hipsters is that still I'm gonna bring
the term back because I feel like
hipster is now a dorky word it's a
derogatory 100 it is a fighting word and
it's I feel corny singing but I'm kind
of trying to bring back a lot of 2008
things like how do you have to how do
you how are you a hipster like I decided
something to Hipster number one they're
in a hat inside hipster okay what
decides a hipster glasses with no
prescription uh-huh scarf with a tank
top
like pins from bands from the 80s you
probably never even listened to let's be
honest a t-shirt with like an impact
font that says something Blockbuster
Video
Lou Reed bad haircut but is it bad on
purpose
the pleasure interviewing
everyone get 100 but you have to do that
I had that impression on SNL he does
have a better version of my haircut
because he has like well yours as a
haircut mine's a haircut and his is a
Joe Dirt I don't think he sees it that
way I think he just thinks it's a
I don't think it's a haircut to him I
think it's just his hair hair I think
it's his hair he was born like that it
was just all hair should look absolutely
I don't think there's any I think he
definitely does it himself
um so hipsters that's interesting
because I do feel like it is very
pejorative term but also I think hipster
it comes into the umbrella of like using
things rejecting technology because you
haven't you're unemployed or have some
kind of trust fund or something you have
the amount of time on your hands to do
shit Twee like you're gonna use a
typewriter instead of a computer I I'm
almost trying to like pull the term
hipster while it's Kicking and Screaming
into 2022 which is like so it's not like
shutter Shades so much as it's now like
you're right like where are we with this
word it's more like car heart but you
don't work in a factory that's exactly
what it is like do we are when I when
you call someone a hipster is it an
insult that's the question
why I said it I was like what's the
meanest thing I can say about another
person and it is to call them a hipster
because it's almost like uh try a try
hard yeah because you know what it is
it's like you're wearing a costume
uh-huh and I think arguably why I can so
boldly say it is because when someone
would look at me they say horrible
haircut horrible clothes
and I mean I look at me do you want to
throw stones no but I but what you're
doing I feel like you and I have a
similar thing where people are like oh
that bitch is crazy based on the way we
present themselves in the world but
we're just having more fun than you do
anytime somebody like because I've
gotten like you know people you know
people being like why are you doing this
I'm like because literally we're
comedians so we never have to like grow
up and go there used to be this thing
where entertainers we're required to
entertain on some level UK Joan Rivers
Phyllis Dillard those bitches weren't
mumus they were in capes they were in
glitter they were in fucking top hats
and shit there was also this thing where
comedians told jokes they didn't do TED
Talks they didn't lecture you how to
vote they didn't tell you about your
sexuality their sexuality or yours
unless there were jokes involved okay
sorry we don't wear hoodies and sneakers
to bore the fuck out of you we're giving
you the old Razzle Dazzle we're giving
you I'm sure jazz dance you know and all
but I do think if you it's it's about to
get worse for you
um let me tell you what you have ahead
of you if you are a woman without kids
do you have kids no okay uh uh one
without kids as you get into your 30s
late Thursdays and you're having fun
people can't they don't you you have to
be on crack you have to be on drugs
you're crazy you're like people just
don't do well with it but it's like I'm
like you two can go on eBay and get this
ridiculous top whatever it's my favorite
place to shop that's where I get all my
clothes absolutely Rachel call me did I
pay 300 bucks nope 40. does it smell
like clam chowder absolutely
is there Speckles of litter like what is
that is there random blood on here no no
probably it's part of History good if I
murder someone this guy's gonna get in
trouble
[Laughter]
so like do you but what I love about you
is you clearly are like doubling down in
a way that is like I love her that I
doubling down is a really good way to
describe everything in my life if I feel
an audience pulling away at a show I
don't necessarily try to reel them back
in with something that's gonna get them
as much as I double down and make it
worse yeah sometimes you have to there's
you mean if like something's not or the
vibe's not working some of my favorite
things uh I've heard for those scenarios
is and this can apply to anyone like we
talk so much on these podcasts about
like esoteric comedy things I'm always
like is this two inside baseball
everyone has to do public fucking
speeches people that listen to podcasts
they give speeches at their
pharmaceutical sales rep companies I
don't know their coaches or whatever so
this applies to every orator
um Fred Armisen was on once and he said
he's like yeah when um when it gets
awkward or when so oh this is when
someone had because when someone heckles
I just I just say nothing and I let it
get really quiet and really boring
so that that's interesting that Heckler
realizes it was better before
torture that yeah just be like yeah no
let let's see your version of this like
maybe yours is better oh that's so funny
I'm like so sick of all my jokes that if
a Heckler enters frame I full blown drop
everything and engage oh love always
absolutely well here's the other thing
though it's like I love hecklers because
and I don't mean like cunt I'm gonna
fuck you with a knife like yeah didn't
love that guy respect that was in
Chicago that is a Cannibal Corpse and
um I think for me this is gonna sound I
don't know narcissistic um but uh uh I
the people that come to comedy shows at
least the ones that I get to do are
funny yes or they know us in some way or
they'll say something funny or dumb or
they have a sense of humor about
themselves enough to where I can make
fun of them and it'll be fine so when
someone heckles I'm not like took them
out I'm like if they think I'm funny
they must not be that they have taste I
mean my arms to get along great but
we're just like if you came to see a
woman do comedy
even if you're not enjoying it you must
be cool on site there's something about
you there's something about I always say
that like you know I feel like this guy
came to the show and he didn't fucking
laugh the whole time I'm like the fact
that a man
came to a show to see a woman talk for
an hour and a half
talk how about come scream yeah so of
course truly complain and nag for an
hour and a half with no chance of having
sex with her at any point just just
listen most men don't listen to their
own girlfriends and wives for an hour
and a half straight without being able
to enter and if you interrupt security
we'll remove you and you do not get your
money back like that is a radical
feminist right so if you have to yell
allowed like fuck you bitch I'm like you
lasted 45 minutes dude good job God but
yeah I'm like stand-up comedy is a live
it's live theater things are gonna
happen in a live theater space and you
have to kind of go with it because then
it gets boring for us it's like I can do
the same hour for my this whole summer
tour every single night but I get bored
of it I'm not encouraging people
no but you know what it is and also it
gives the audience this a feeling of
like oh my like only we got to see
experience whereas I think that like
people come see live shows now the
people that see live shows now I love
even more because they have so many
reasons to say home right and there's
they can see all of your stuff online as
many times as they want and they have
the best seat in the house yeah so when
they choose to come to a show I'm like I
fuck with you people and I'm gonna give
you like a show that you couldn't get
anywhere else so when someone huckles it
helps you with that totally so let me
tell you let me ask you because you were
let me tell you let me let me tell you
um uh about your story
um you were in Chicago and you were at
the Groundlings uh right
is there growings in Chicago I did like
a second City I I didn't even do seconds
I was mostly doing stand-up in Chicago
okay good I like you so much more now
right okay so Chicago I am interested in
this because I'm kind of fascinated by
what kind of comedians come out of which
cities and climates like Boston
comedians are like very specific you
know like Bill Burr and
um uh uh what's his name again Louis CK
those type of guys and then DC's like
Chappelle and me
um and uh Chicago is like very specific
yeah Sebastian and you I mean it's
amazing
I'm obsessed with him he like he is my
dad looks and sounds exactly like that
so I project a lot of stuff on him that
he doesn't know about a lot of people do
like I project that we're friends yeah
absolutely yeah well you guys are yeah
I'm burping well probably that you can
use this okay yeah no totally we'll have
it'll be a sound it'll be that's this is
how we came into each other's lives a
viral sound there you go you guys
remember on the podcast when we had
Miranda Cosgrove and I was like what's
your favorite curse word and she's like
probably fuck I actually do cuss a
little do you also what's your favorite
curse word probably fuck
your impression of the good for you
podcast is you guys as you guys uh might
know uh she was the lucky one selected
absolutely I was I know this sounds
ridiculous you're honest and now you
don't need anyone to affirm how talented
you are I love it but when I saw you do
the impression of the with lizzo you all
you had to do because it seems like what
everyone really was making fun of was my
horrendous laugh which again you know
what look I'm having fun and
um I've always had a horrific laugh and
I don't have to use mace or anything you
know scared men away and it's kept me
safe on streets at night and in
dangerous alleys but um the the choice
you made so basically she just had to uh
do an impression of me laughing like a
maniac and the fact that you just went
you you you did your eyes went up and
your head kind of went down actually
[Applause]
do you remember you do that in the cliff
yes they like showed me the clip and
first of all I was like excited because
you had pink hair in that clip yeah and
I was like oh I have to wear a pink wig
and they like made me watch it over and
over again and I do I think I do the
head movement you do in the clip you do
us you do like like the perfect parody
of it which is uh exaggerating in a tiny
bit no but you're like
like your eyes like went up in your head
well I'm gonna do is gonna be demented
yeah it was like the per you know what
it was because it it captured the
essence of it in the best way and it's
the essence of it is like not just the
clip anymore it's like the fact that
those sound bites Loop over and over
again which makes it more like demented
yeah it's completely made like chaos yes
and the best part about it is that
everyone see we'll see until SNL this is
what fucked me up everyone thought it
was Miranda's laugh oh I know and yeah
and it was like so and then once the
clip the original clip went around then
all of a sudden I was like oh no wonder
like Miranda could never be that
annoying yeah
being big is everyone's like when you
realize Amanda or um Amanda Miranda
Cosgrove had such an annoying laugh
because it was the way that it clipped I
think I was out of frame and it was just
hard it was just my voice and then the
clip started circulating with me in it
oh really so I was like I was like there
is a chance I'm gonna get off the hook
here and No One's Gonna know it was me
that's funny I I was able because the
hardest thing to do is like do a
convincing fake laugh basically because
that's so hard I like people can
probably crying is hard but genuine
laughter is hard to feign basically but
lizzo was being really funny she is a
fucking
like she's like not like she did a
couple of those and one of the choices
she I'm just obsessed with people's like
choices like I like to get really
granular and she did one iteration of
that video or was like what's your
favorite curse word probably fuck and we
start laughing and she just runs to the
camera she just charged to the camera oh
I actually do cuss a little do you also
what's your favorite curse word probably
fuck
why did that become viral
do you awesome what's your favorite
curse word
[Music]
I this for the first time in my life
feel old because I do not understand
Tick Tock I understand a video that
shows me how to make quick tater tots or
how to you know whatever I I posted a
video where I'm cutting a cake with
dental floss millions of you I get that
because it's like little things like
that I'm like yes and I'm gonna send
this to my friends why is sound goes
viral I I don't know the one I I
downloaded Tick Tock for one second
though because I got obsessed with this
woman who feeds her dogs raw meat she
feeds them like raw duck heads and like
Pig uteruses and I go oh okay I can kind
of get why I'm like I'm obsessed with
watching this woman put a full like
Rooster's penis in a dog's smell and
then everything out my understanding
Falls like so I was just watching it for
porn yeah I was jerking off to watching
a dog sucking a cat's dick and then
anyway what were you talking about
I don't know I don't under and then you
know because I'm just curious if it's in
because when you're on SNL and you're
and you're deciding what sketches to
come up with and what's going to be
popular it's like is the conversation
like oh hey this was big on Tick Tock we
should spoof it on the show you know
like is that something that now is
obviously legitimate in a platform to
where you guys incorporate it in because
you're like this is obviously relevant I
like
my sketch writing process is almost like
what is something we can make that will
will get a sued to show on television
like I'm like I feel like I'm like
antiviral like it's like everything I
come up with is like oh God
what's your favorite thing so far that
you've that hasn't gone on yet that has
we've written like a bunch of like
really disgusting sketches that are
haven't made it onto the show just
because I like fucked it up and like I'm
learning how to do the show right but
they are like letting me try
I'm gonna ask some questions from the
internet oh oh you've talked a lot about
your SNL Edition I bet right
no I don't know how would you do I don't
think so I understand that I couldn't
find it just you just did stand up in
front of Lauren or you did it at a club
and he came and saw you I did JFL
and I I did what was the pandemic JFL
um just for laughs Comedy Festival
should I explain it no I mean yeah
Google it guys so I just did and it was
the pandemic version of JFL so it was
just a show at Dynasty typewriter wow 10
minutes from my house didn't have to
think about it and they filmed it and he
saw it or he was just there I think they
I don't know who was there to be honest
I just walked in did some did it seven
minutes of Comedy didn't have to fly to
Montreal
then you just get a call
and then they like have you do like the
whole like audition process after that
yeah and so you went to New York and
just did
a stand up again God bless in front of
Lauren yes
God bless just the same set it's like
you know yeah and like because I I do
not have a background in like characters
and sketch and anything like that
what is there any celebrity Impressions
that are like you're thinking about
I'm gonna do a really good Cartman
oh I can't do an impression I can't do
anything you Pro but you probably have
some that you'll just stumble on I'm
sure if like a gun was put to my head I
could do an impression of someone
getting shot in the head yeah
[Laughter]
okay uh no she is not single stop asking
what's the story behind the mullet I've
had a mullet for 10 years by the way and
all of a sudden I mean it's like you
know it's the thing now and all these
like because they're going for the red
States yes whatever giddy up
um do I mean of course do you like
working at SNL I like are you a night
owl are you the hours like doable it's
literally yes because it's like I'm
literally getting paid for the first
time in my life to just literally write
comedy all the time and I'm like this is
a gift from God I'm like full of
gratitude yeah it sounds like just the
most fun ever it's just foot like you
you don't like you get paid to be a
comedian like what's better than that
I've never been like this is like
iraqs what is her process working with
Colin to do her update sketch he
literally the the please don't destroy
boys and Celeste diem write those bits
with me and we just write like the
meanest things
and he lets us
yeah
literally the bid works because he's
laughing and smiling and loving it it's
amazing it's just like I'm perfect and
none of this works like the jokes are
literally like like Johansson do say
whatever you want yeah all right he's
like he's doing the you laugh yeah
um so let me ask you who did you look up
to who are your comedic influences
growing up
um I mean like I grew up like addicted
to the nanny I was like obsessed with
Seinfeld like fascinating I just wanted
to be like a colorful Jewish comedian
who shopped at filene's basement and got
those like Technicolor Moschino like
suits or whatever by the way you know
who you remind me of a little bit do you
ever know um nardoir
we have the same I had the same pants
General aesthetic doing
[Laughter]
like the comedic influences are like
that you know like I was like obsessed
with peewee's Playhouse yeah yeah like
Paul Reubens is like of course a God to
me and there was something of like let
me ask you because it seems like from
what I've gleaned like I've heard you I
listened on a couple podcasts you don't
do a ton of them no I'm not like great
at podcasts to be honest no no one is
but you're good at it you're good at
talking I'm not that good at talking I
talk a lot that's different than being
good at doctors
and I'm terrified of Silence it's a
different thing absolutely because when
you hear the silence what you fear the
darkness I find that to me that a lot of
comedians who uh are into more like
silly
comedy which I believe comedy should be
I think we forgot about like silliness
and that we are clowns come from a lot
of darkness in their past and they
needed like a silliness as a respite
that's kind of how I was but it seems
like you had a very loving let's talk
about I the only thing thing I like to
talk about more than the trauma of like
child abuse and neglect and alcoholism
is the trauma of parents that loved you
I have full there is I had full 1 000
support for my entire family like truly
just wanted to be a comedian since I was
like 2.2 years old and like my parents
were always supportive and there is like
pressure in that because they were like
oh shit they have like on dying faith in
me I best I hope I don't fuck this up
I'm getting never-ending love from like
two angelic Angels Sent From Heaven but
did they like push you in the direction
of certain kinds of Comedy because they
knew that's what you wanted or did like
how did you fall upon like silly comedy
Pee-wee's Playhouse Etc I mean they
definitely like showed me like Sherry
Lewis's lamb chop and like The Nanny and
like you know did you watch SNL I did a
little yeah my parents show like you
know and that was always like my mom's
dream for me was like one day you're
gonna be on Saturday Night Live and I
was like you know I don't know that's
not like you don't really like have that
as a dream because it's so like the
chances of it happening are like slim to
none
so I was just I don't know but I I I
didn't get into like stand up until like
a little later in my life or maybe I was
well no not later because I knew I
wanted to be a comedian at a young age
but I didn't really know what that meant
yeah and then when I was like they don't
have pageants for comedians
like they have Pat beauty pageants for
children but they don't have comedy
pageants well anytime that there's a
there's a stand-up who's younger than me
they are a child yeah
they and like then when I got into stand
up like like later my teens or you know
early 20s or something I was like
obsessed with like Maria Bamford and
like Todd Berry and yeah yeah yeah Todd
Berry has like God he used to do this
joke that was so funny and so I hate the
word brave but just so like I'm obsessed
with jokes that you can only pull off if
you were just an expert at the and I'm
calling it a craft because when Todd
Berry does it it feels like a craft of
building attention so he you know talks
really slowly and allows the tension to
build and it's you know what I I don't
know if it's being a girl I'm not trying
to play the gender card but I do feel
like my laughs per minute have to be
pretty high like there's as a woman you
don't get a lot of in uh self-indulgent
uh wiggle room on stage to draw things
out because your voice is so
high-pitched and shrill that is yeah and
I have wrinkles on my face and
everyone's nauseous because of it you
know and I'm aging so that's already an
assault visually on the crowd and my
thighs touch which is just disgusting
and um they didn't sign up to see this
pig just like and not tell jokes and
um and so he's uh he's talking about um
you know Brad He's like Brad Pitt he's
like you know I'm not gonna do an
impression of of Todd Berry not that I
can but I'm also going to try not to
embarrass myself
um I don't want to intimidate you yeah
so he's like so how many of you uh think
Brad Pitt is hot you know
screaming experience things like that
and it gets really quiet and he goes um
so if you had the choice of sleeping
with Brad Pitt or me how many of you
would sleep with Brad Pitt and
he's like how many stupid men dead
silence it was like at his show people
that paid to come see him right and then
he's like okay okay so if Brad Pitt had
like I think it goes into this direction
like lost both his legs
and your choice was between
having sex with Brad Pitt with no legs
or me would it be Brad Pitt with the
legs I was like he's like or me dead
silent he goes okay and then he does
like a couple more iterations of it and
it's always people want to fuck Brad
Pitt and he goes got it because I have
news for you guys
Brad Pitt would never have sex with any
of you
it's just a perfect joke it's a perfect
it's like like a patient tense build
with such a payoff and no one saw where
it was going and those are the type of
things you're just like that's just 30
years I wish I could just do I wish I
could just say something funny you know
what I mean
I a lot of my stand-up is very like it's
very physical High effort
like uh High effort low payoff kind of
that's not true
and like like in my hour show is like
there's like crazy video PowerPoint like
multimedia stuff okay and it's like I
think about Todd Berry and I'm like if I
like could just like stand there and not
like flail my arms around and just talk
confidently and slowly and get a laugh
like what would that feel like because
I'm gonna say just being like you know
like hello you know well that's I mean
who know I mean we would have to talk to
Todd about how he probably started you
know in a different way you know it's
interesting because I went the opposite
way when I first started it was like if
you're just a stand-up in L.A and you're
at the comedy store if you try it all
you are a dork you're lame you're
pathetic you're embarrassing yourself
um so I would be as dry as I possibly
could with like the dirtiest jokes to
neuter myself and I was just trying to
make the like mean comedians in the back
that hated me laugh so it was just like
pussy pussy pussy pussy but it's like
you know and
um using any energy was like lame or
hacky that's so funny because I think of
like I mean when I think of like The
Comedy Store I think of like like Sam
canister and Jim Carrey yeah but yeah I
mean my last special is like I am on the
ground most of the time and I just
there's a little bit of a uh unfair like
um I think it really is it's it's like
the jocks and the Nerds all over again
everything's just High School all over
again it's like if you try too hard
you're like Tracy flick you're like like
why are you like putting so much energy
into this like people paid money all
right to see that do you mind if I try
is that okay there's doctors and nurses
and teachers they could be anywhere else
right now but they're here looking at
you give them a show like Let Me Maybe
Just I'm so sorry I'm not reading off my
notebook going what else is happening
I've written down a joke in years so
hold on real quick yes I want to talk
about your pen ancient for the grotesque
yes would you call it that absolutely
and what is it when did this start did
it come from horror movies are you
squeamish when it comes to actual body
guts it's so it comes from like a true
like basically i s um the art that I was
doing visual art that was like I was
doing stand up and then I was doing
visual art that was all like intestines
coming out of a butthole or whatever and
then I was like oh my God I can marry
comedy and visual art with like crazy
like I do like weird crazy projection
video stuff with my stand up
um and it's like
you know
it's I think I mean for lack of a better
way to say it a lot of my stuff is like
body Horror in the you know it's a it's
horrible to have a female body a lot of
times yes female identifying body and so
a lot of it comes from like you know
full just discomfort with being a like
Jew with too many pubes right like it
all and no diarrhea
time and then a lot of but like um
finding you know it is
because I am
it does come from genuine like
fear and
um revulsion a lot of my work is trying
to find the beauty in it and that's
where like the Technicolor pink sparkly
blooded guts come from because we all
have a body and we have to deal with it
somehow there it is so wild because they
never it bodies are just a nightmare
they're a nightmare it's a we are trash
bags full of blood we're trash bags full
of blood and we do horrible painful
things to ourselves to distract from the
fact that we're aging and hideous
don't look like what we're supposed to
look like I mean we do such wild shit
like I remember when all the Britney
stuff was happening like because it was
reappening and we were rehashing it
obviously in the last year or so but
like when they were talking about how
crazy it was when she shaved her head
like she shaved her head and I was like
the only thing crazier than shaving your
head as a woman is what we all do which
is sew in someone else's hair someone
else's someone else's hair don't know
who it is or where it came from put it
in and pretend it's hours
with like clips and just like like like
Buffalo Bill basically truly or like
Hannibal Lecter like you put skin on
like putting out someone else does your
suit full of skin like gross but when
you put someone else's hair on your head
you're just beautiful to I moisturize
with
um like that snail excretion and stuff
that's like a Korean beauty thing sure
sure and it's like you know I don't
really it's a serum you don't really
think about it but then I watched a
YouTube video of how they extract the
snail serum and they get a bunch of
snails in like a tank and steam them up
and get them hot and horny and they
basically come into a jar
and that's what I'm putting on my face I
don't really think about that yeah it's
so it's body horror
I'm bathing in snail cum
you need to do it I don't need to by the
way
I want to look barely legal for the rest
of my life like what like when you're
put like when you really stop and think
about it like when you're I'm when I'm
putting a pence a crayon it on in on my
eyelid on my eyelid and then in the
water line I'm like this is so
disgusting it's disgusting like I'm
gussing up a soon-to-be corpse as soon
to be and the the thing that you're
gussing up is a mucous membrane that's
touching your eyeball like and if you
look into my eyes whether it's uh framed
with a velvety liner or not you're gonna
see veins that have blood going through
like it's just eyes are gross they're
disgusting they're they you know that I
had to learn that when you have
conjunctivitis pink eye in one eye it
can give it to the the other eye just by
like jumping over no they're not
connected no I mean they just that's the
biggest thing right right you can say
your eyeballs aren't attached to
anything no they're loose literally like
I I for the show I had to learn how to
put in context for the first time yeah
because we're reading cue cards and it's
not that I had a way to ruin the magic
of SNL
do you think if you think I can rotate
if you think I have a memory like
memorize lines and retain any
information you're wrong but like the I
I struggled with it because it's not
like I was grossed out about touching my
eyeball but I was like there are like
involuntary my muscles for the past 29
yeah I'm 29 if you can believe it for
the past 29 years of my life my eyelids
have been trained to do everything in
their power to keep foreign objects out
from my eyeball yeah yeah so it was just
like you're raping your eyeball yes with
contacts it was a medieval torture
device my own think my talents are you
not allowed to wear glasses on the show
well you know sometimes he's not the
character it's just right sometimes
[Laughter]
and so have you had any like bones
broken or surgeries or anything I've had
bones I think the first my first true
exploration into like body horror comedy
or whatever was like I did a piece about
like
um I'm well
I I was just obsessed with the like
cruel and like medieval
techniques we use for like hair removal
like pouring hot wax on the most
delicate and protected part of your body
your full pussy lips yeah and then
wrenching them out to the point where
like you're you're losing like a whole
layer of skin and hair you're bleeding
and this is just normal it's normal it's
a practice you have to do to so you can
like uh be a part of I feel like shaving
is normal should go I've waxed maybe
once and I was just like I'm I'm I I
don't need to keep doing that like yes I
think if you go do it once got it if you
just keep going back you like it well
there is there's ways to get rid of your
pubic hair that does not involve that
process you don't have Jewish pubes
because truly every hair on my body is a
pube okay it's you
oh let me see
but you're not trying you don't try to
shave that you didn't you just have full
armpit hair out I could grow out a full
armpit hair and like
1.5 weeks I could grow a unibrow in half
that time
mine is on my face and on my chin at
least yours is hidden I have a full
beard now I have a full goatee no I I
just have to pluck it you have to pluck
it I kind of like the feeling it when it
starts growing out in your chin I like
to kind of feel it and then yeah I have
to pop my chin probably three times a
week yes yes and then I'll get ingrown
tears and my guy thank god he's a
veterinarian you know he digs it out
and then I have random course pubes that
just grow out of the side of my face
black is nice why do you think what is
the biological basis for moles having
giant coarse hairs come out of them
because moles aren't ugly enough they're
like you know what else we should
probably add a smither's hair because
God said why be why would I let you be
happy for more than one second doesn't
mean you ate that Apple fair and square
or whatever the fuck happened in the
garden okay so a lot of it is the hair
removed so you have no hair removal
Solutions besides waxing well so then
like all of this like and then I was
making these like crazy videos where I
was like
I I like so that's where like my body
horror Obsession like came from making
these like and like a lot of my stand-up
talking about it and then I was making
these videos where I was like dressed up
as a hair in a cross-section of skin and
getting like my head chopped off with a
huge razor blade and like blood spurting
out where are you on um zip popping
pimple popper videos and stuff not you
nothing I make my own
see you're good I should no I'm telling
you there's a teacher on there who's
making two million dollars a year
breastfeeding are you serious yeah she
was back over red she can breastfeed for
how long I think it's that's a great
point
maybe she had twins
I know my friend can squeeze liquid out
of his nipple just anytime he wants he
should call a doctor absolutely for sure
the grossest thing ever is are you
you're in to grow stuff or not yo I am
but it comes from like a deep I think a
lot of people are like oh Sarah squirm
likes gross stuff so she probably love
that I'm gonna bring a bag of my own
shit to the show bummer and it's like
you know what I am curious were you into
Garbage Pail Kids oh I have I have a
Garbage Pail Kids okay this is one okay
Sarah slime oh my I was zitty Whitney
well I was yeah I think it was zitty
witty or something like that so I had
them all over my door I had them taped
all over the uh front and back of like
my door to my room I was completely
obsessed I wanted to do an animated show
based on it but everyone's like no well
have you seen the live action there yeah
yes but also by the way you look back
some of that stuff is I am not the
person that's like you guys this is
problematic some of those are rough
absolutely they're like aborted Albert
you're like we pass back it's like he's
got half a coat hanger through his head
you're like Jesus guys it's pretty good
it's childbirth in your realm of body uh
oh my God that's a big one it's have you
you I've watched a bunch of childbirth
video like you know what I mean the only
one I've really watched is the one where
there was a kid that needed surgery in
utero and they took him out to give him
surgery and put them back in now wait
you haven't seen this and then and then
his little hand reached up and grabbed
the doctor's finger do you not want kids
no
um no so what is that I feel like
there's this 30 and under is just it
doesn't even because that's how I was
when I was your age is that gonna stick
or are you me or is the next Generation
just like kids are like slap bracelets
at this point where are you at on it
where I am now is I do need a new hour
of material I just shot a special it
just yeah
um here's the thing I I will tell you
number one I was like kids probably not
for me I have all this um shitty DNA I
don't want to pass on if I do have a kid
I would probably adopt having your own
kid at this point is like buying a dog
from a breeder like there's so many kids
I'm just saying I'm a like dog I'm an
animal rescue person why there's so many
kids in Appalachia that are born into
the foster care system addicted to
opioids I could do that we have
something in common we could do drugs
together
whatever or so I was like if I want kids
I can adopt I did freeze my eggs when I
was 33. just just did not have to think
about it and then that took so much
pressure off maybe too much pressure
because I was like I got all the time in
the world Janet Jackson had a kid at 55
she also has two billion dollars
absolutely because she married some like
Saudi guy
um and now after my dad died
a primordial thing kind of came over me
that was like I need to carry on the DNA
like some reptilian
thing was like I want something that
looks like him which could have just
been my grief trying to heal itself I
just I feel like for the first time in
my life I have something going on like I
was in full Panic like you know I was
doing comedy for like you know I mean
not that long whatever I can't complain
but like for the first time I'm like I
have a job things are going okay God
willing my lips are God's ears whatever
um so it's like I can't imagine taking
account for I just don't want to be
responsible oh you have like 12 15 years
I mean you could but I'm I'm fascinated
by I know a lot of people that are like
younger now they're like it's like
irresponsible to bring a child into this
world oh no I'm just like obsessed with
thinking about myself all the time to me
but that's like that's the way to do it
to go to like know what you're capable
of in your bandwidth and what you have
so my brain goes like okay when my dogs
die which will never happen or will
happen in 400 years
um I will I can see myself doing I just
can't see myself either carrying it I
can't see myself carrying it I've got I
can hardly fucking carry a purse at this
point I do a backpack I can't carry a
purse much I see people in the airport
with their kids and I'm just like it's
like they have a full they're just
surrounded by shit from like Petco they
just have bags and water bowls and it's
just they're messing I just can't
because my thing is if I have a kid I
don't want to travel for five years
uh-huh I'm not going anywhere with the
child drinking up an airplane I have
friends that are like I'm taking my
daughter to Paris I'm like how old is
she three are you why are you ruining
everyone in paris's day with your child
that's not even gonna remember any of
the shit that happens there your tragedy
smells weird like why would you do that
to these Parisian whatever like I just I
think that yeah that's a thing and I
also need a wife right right I would
need like I'm big on like I would want
help right I just can't imagine like my
all of my plans for my life are like
have nothing to do with taking care of a
little fucking parasite like I've never
and it's funny because now like people
you know like it just comes up with
friends you know because my friends were
older and it comes up all the time I'm
like and everyone's like whoa your
biological clock is gonna start ticking
I'm like I can't even imagine that
happening there's no such I could not
when I was trying to could not wrap my
head around it I still can't totally
wrap my head around it but I also can't
picture myself like
with no little thing you got a bunch of
little things running around like I got
tons I could do because also I was kind
of raised by you know my two aunts in
Virginia and they didn't have kids they
were just horse dog ladies I mean I have
an aunt that had 14 dogs and cats and
people would just drop dogs at the house
and tie them up like if they were sick
and she'd just have to take them and had
like horses and was like it's like the
happiest person I know right so I'm like
I can I could go that way I have a lot
of nightmares that I am extremely
pregnant and I have a painful birth and
I give birth to a creature that is
either like a frozen ice baby with wires
coming out of its head or like a fucking
monster that might be how babies are
born in five years yeah that is frozen
put them in the blender or whatever and
like all of it is like like it it it's
like this like my unconscious being like
um telling me like about my anxieties
about my own work and stuff so the only
time I'm ever thinking about like
childbirth or pregnancy it's like always
related to Metaphor yeah because like
your work is your baby yes so never for
a goddamn second am I interpreting that
like symbology as like no you want a kid
it's like no what is it you should never
have again
that's when I wake up and I tell my
boyfriend I'm like have this dream or I
had a kid and I because I get these like
intrusive thoughts and I dropped it and
it's uh teeth got stuck in the like
marble of like the floor or something
and he's like it sounds like you're you
have kids on the brain I'm like it
sounds like I should never have kids
there's like it's actually a metaphor
for
um God so don't talk actually should be
single also so no man's place to marry a
billionaire
um which by the way I can't stop saying
that because
um uh I want to ask about your
relationship but did you see the Teal
Swan documentary I haven't but I know
I'm gonna be liking this okay
we need to talk about it
and I'm gonna do a whole episode on it
because I'm obsessed because
because
she she like makes people kill
themselves she uh
I have personal liability insurance you
can say that if you were on all day long
but yeah no she that is like I think to
me not even the most compelling part is
it's more like she's this
um you know self-proclaimed like
spiritual leader in
and look I I I I don't think that she's
intending to do anything super malicious
I think on some level like she her
people hurt people and whatever who
cares the point is that every time she
gets like annoyed or someone tries to
like come up against her like she's also
like stunning and gorgeous hair and
every she's had five husbands every now
and then she's like look I don't need to
do this I mean I could just like marry a
billionaire oh my God I'm gonna start
saying that she'll just think throw that
out she's like I don't need this shit
okay I could like marry a billionaire
it's like you guys should be so lucky
that I'm doing this like how dare you
challenge me and like if you're not
careful I'm Gonna Leave You All and just
marry a billionaire
just like pure unbridled confidence
making everyone shake in their boots by
the way not even like a rich guy
like a billionaire like I don't mean
like how many are there it's just like
my cheekbones are high enough to get the
one of seven by the way that's like her
plan B which is so fun funny
taking a break
to whine about wine
now here's the thing about wine I like
it in my belly I want it in my belly I
want it in my bloodstream I want when
mosquitoes bite me for them to just pass
out because they're drunk because that's
how much wine is in the system but I
don't know how to store wine yeah and I
believe it or not don't finish the whole
bottle whoa usually unless it's Friday
and Emily and I got in a spat yeah and I
don't know how to get the cork back in
so I always finish the bottle once you
put it in your pussy
I once
you're not supposed to put in your pussy
first I think that's but that's how you
store it at the right temperature
perfectly chilled perfectly I see in
cobwebby
and dry summertime heat and vaginas can
spoil wine ah and you got to get those
boxes out of your pussies off your
countertops and protect them with a wine
fridge from wine enthusiasts Wine
Enthusiast designs and offers the
largest selection of wine coolers for
every Drinker every budget and every
size collection from six to six hundred
bottles plus expert wine storage
Consultants are available by phone to
help you find the right fit for all your
needs ma'am take it out of your bus
[Laughter]
did you plug it in and I'm like yeah
it's right in my pussy and they're like
no did you plug in the fridge you're
like no I'll get electrocuted so we
fooled me once vibrator
so Emily and I got our Wine Enthusiast
fridge it is
stunning and not only that they make
incredible unique accessories they make
glassware they make furniture wine
storage gifts and more visit wine
enthusiast.com or Texaco gfy to five
eleven five eleven don't miss wine
enthusiasts July 4th Wine Cellar and
Furniture happy birthday marker save up
to 25 on wine cellars and Fine Furniture
now through July 4th text gfy to 5 11 5
11 today to see for yourself text gfy to
511 511 today certain exclusions May
apply you may receive up to one
additional text fees May apply Tech Stop
to opt out I'm a wine enthusiast
enthusiast
I'm a text Enthusiast now if that didn't
make you pee your pants my show on July
1st will in West Hampton Beach New
Jersey nope
New York look that was whoa I'm gonna
get snipered in the neck that is like
the most insulting thing you can say to
someone in West Hampton and now the New
Jersey people are going to say basically
Newark Guys West Hampton July 4th I'm
going to be at the West Hampton Beach
perform uh that's not July 4th I'm not
going to be competing with America's
birthday right although and the wine
enthusiasts sale did you know that did
you know that Larry the Cable Guy is so
big in Nebraska where he's from that his
schedule didn't permit that he could
perform there any day except July 4th so
they moved uh the fireworks in July 4th
celebrations to the fifth so he could
perform on the fourth that's the kind of
power I longed for moving a national
holiday to do jokes about how much you
hate dogs
and the me too movement this is when
Emily did stand up I don't know if you
caught this episode back in the day
where I played uh forcibly uh publicly
shamed Emily with her uh her stand-up
sets which the first one opened with so
I hate dogs
um I just love pandas because Ollie do
is sleep and try to extinct themselves
and then her other opener was so the
metoo movement is here long overdue
anyway
so sorry that I'm like tearing socially
usually sorry you're using your platform
responsibly July 4 1st oh wow I am too
enthusiastic about wine I've already had
a bunch today clearly West Hampton Beach
Performing Arts Center come out Tory
Burch see you there September 8th I'll
be in Cincinnati Ohio with the Taft
theater this will be all new material
whoa I know I've been writing lots of
jokes uh I it's touch and go but there's
lots of sport jokes coming in hot
September 9th I'm gonna be in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania at the Miller
Theater September 10th ooh that's
six days after my birthday
that was a real that was me doing math
broke my brain September 10th I'll be in
Richmond Virginia at the national
September 24th I'm in Charlottesville
Virginia cannot wait Paramount Theater
back to back to the show
um your relationship how long has this
been going on eight years whoa I
honestly I'm like oh do you know about
Saturn returns I'm I've I did it you
didn't parented I got actually literally
in the when my Saturn return happened I
like can you explain the concept it's
you know your Saturn goes back to
whatever fucking house from when you
were born or whatever and you're like
stars rewind or whatever and bullshit
fucking whatever and then that's when
you like fully like come to your own and
repair it and like get your fucking shit
together and it's like a hard time in
their life but you're fully like
self-actualized or whatever like between
27 and 29 everyone goes through like a
major shift in some way it's like yes I
think it's based in some astrological
thing also like before you turn 30 I do
I do believe there's just a A lot
changes when you're moving out of your
20s yeah you know what I mean you
probably you know they say that if
you've been with someone uh your whole
life or for a while you'll always go
through a breakup or break up with them
or rethink the relationship uh from 27
to 29 so I was I remember I was dating a
guy and he's like are you gonna break up
with me because you're Saturn returns
it's just kind of a thing that's bad
yeah he was let around like you seem
dumb enough to believe in astrology
um that uh 27 to 29 is a time when so
many fun so much of you fundamentally
changes that you like quit your job you
move out of your parents house you get a
new car you you know switch vocations
you find out who you want to be you
break up with the person you're with you
cheat like something big happens yes
well I got um I got hired on SNS that
was my Saturn return I was like God
big change but does he live in New York
he I dragged his ass to New York I've
been dragging him all over the country
fucking patients two days long he's a
normal
human being okay like what does that
mean he's new he's normal and he's good
and he's not a comedian here's the other
thing I love about what you're saying is
I do that too where I'm like the guy
that I'm the guy I'm dating is a
Critical Care Veterinarian okay like
he's like but I always am like he's like
a normal and he's like well he's dating
you you can't beat that normally like
hangs out with like dogs all day he's a
freak
um so uh okay so really quick your
Saturn return is an astrological event
that occurs every 27 to 29.5 years when
the patterns plattern we're in your
platter I'm in such a rush I like to
remix words when the planet Saturn
returns to the sign and degree that it
was when you were born It's associated
with major life changes like career
changes breakups engagements and
relocation
um okay so he does what
he is a grant writer
barely know what that is
I'm like literally you know what I'm
like afraid my my best friend Ruby was
like don't let people know you have a
fucking boyfriend because they're not
gonna buy tickets to come to the show
okay okay if they do because they think
you're single you don't want those
people at your show anyway who Ruby put
together it's like Myers Ruby says 67
year old woman from Brooklyn yes
it was smoke cigars
while I'm doing laundry with a spoon yes
in The Cauldron make sure they think
you're single I true I don't know like
all of my single friends who go through
the fucking hell shit that is comedy
it's like to come at the fact that I had
like stability and like fucking eating
shit every single night getting my ass
handed to me on a fucking plate and then
I have to eat my own ass out of like
when you have to eat your Grant writer's
ass yeah you either grandma like going
through the meat grinder of like comedy
and show business like alone I can't
imagine and I had like I've had a
fucking person with me the whole time so
that I could like eat shit at a show
come home and he's like man you're great
don't worry about it I'm like oh my God
the fact that people don't have that I
can't even imagine it's this I'm so glad
this came up because
um uh I learned a long time ago not that
long ago I learned it a long time ago
didn't employ it until like six months
ago that who your uh who you decide to
be with who you choose in your personal
life is a business decision and who you
marry is a business decision who you're
dating is a business decision because
that person's either going to energize
you or deplete you and that's either
going to support or combat your
professional goal so you look at the
people with and these are
generalizations I don't know what goes
on behind closed doors but when you look
at some of the grades when you look at
Steve Carell and Will Ferrell and like
they have been married for 25 years they
have stable relation they're not like
dating a different Starlet every week
and it's like that um is it flow bear I
always get this quote wrong uh here we
go Be steady and well ordered in your
life so that you can be fierce and
original in your work so it's like the
idea that like if you come home to drama
if you come home to chaos like you're
not gonna have the energy to be able to
make the good chaos for work like I
think when I first started especially is
a comedian that like talks about
relationships I was like I need to be in
something chaotic and we need to fight
everybody so that our writing TV shows
you're like I need to have good stories
I need to have good jokes and now you're
like no I'm actually just kind of need
to sleep eight hours and not worry
someone's cheating on yeah you need to
be healthy you don't need to be like
have 12 boyfriend like I need like a
glass of water you need
her
person that I met we've been dating
since I'm like 20ish like the I he's the
only good person in the world and it's
like we're we're comedians we're we
travel around all the time we meet a
million people and it's like yeah I've
met 38 400 million people in my life and
it's like no one seems to be as good of
a person as him he's an angel Sent From
Heaven that is it actually makes me
think he's twice as good as you think
because you can't come from love like
your bar for love is high yes yes and he
is pure he's a pure beam of light and
love how did you meet
I've I'm forced him to date me yeah he
was my we worked we're gonna fit right
in in Hollywood
anyway
like he we worked at the college radio
station and like I was like uh do you
want to go on a day and he was like No
And I was like totally
why did he say no because I was like way
younger than him this is he was like my
boss at the radio say this was like what
a psychotic he was my boss at the radio
station and he was like well that would
kind of be like
um inappropriate abuse of power and this
wasn't like 2012 or whatever and I was
like I had never even heard of that
before and I was like he like invented
and then you're like do you have power I
want a date even more oh my God what's
up you're abusive hello hello so I just
convinced him to date me are you gonna
get married do you think or would you
I feel like we're both resistant to
getting married but we would both have
the funniest weddings we would have oh
my by the way everyone wants us to get
married so they can get invited I'm I
a funeral I've already planned it's
gonna be the most fun shit ever but um
uh like I just feel like we'd have such
fun weddings what a change no it would
be like a really cool party and like
really cool people would be there but
you don't have to sign a thing you don't
like my thing is like I could do the
party the ring but I don't have to sign
anything I don't need to get the state
involved I think after like like eight
years of like DIY touring where it's
like I spent like all of my waking hours
being like planning a show in a basement
in Pittsburgh and like whatever it's
like throwing an event
that's not a show or something I want
you know what I mean I was planning a
wedding a couple years ago for myself
you were planning a wedding yeah you
weren't anymore I was engaged and I was
trying to plan a wedding
and it really fell apart very quickly
and I felt very overwhelmed because I
was like I have been taught to believe
this is fun when my friends are planning
weddings it's fun I like being involved
I like picking this up I love doing
seating charts oh my favorite thing ever
that's my favorite thing ever and um
I uh but I was like this is basically
like what we do for a living I'm putting
on a show I'm picking a venue it's like
or being a showrunner it's like I'm
getting flowers I'm getting a uh I'm
booking a hotel and then also it's even
worse because it's like I book these
venues for Productions of TV or film or
I know what they cost right this isn't
what they call it's such a racket I'm
like why was I quoted six thousand when
I tried to book this for a TV show and
now it's twenty thousand if I try to
book it for a wedding is it really like
that oh flowers you've bought flowers
before
I like Walgreens
I just mean when you buy them for a
wedding they're all of a sudden like
twelve thousand dollars remember how
much is paper I don't like a penny a
penny and then you put gold writing on
it saying we're getting married here and
all of a sudden it's seven thousand
dollars for invitations for the first
time my life have a dollar to my name so
it's like I've not like people have to
spend money to get married
well you can if you would pull your
fucking name together you could do paid
Partnerships but no one knows what your
name is oh my gosh
oh my because are you like everything in
your life is so much work that it's like
don't you want to just like hang out
kick it yeah I just got to that point do
you have like an iron deficiency
yes really I do
I don't eat that much red meat
is that why I'm tired I'm so tired yeah
do you it might be an iron thing are you
taking NAD no you know I don't know
about this so what do you mean you're in
the Illuminati you're not working now
apparently they give you nine random
shots we have to get our own coffee
[Laughter]
do you feel like because everyone wants
to talk now about how it must be so hard
to be a comedian right now it's like you
can't say anything anymore which is
funny to me because I'm like there's
like two words there n-word and tranny I
feel like there are a lot of words we
can say I'm literally like what's it
shouldn't be that hard to say something
that doesn't hurt people's feelings you
know what else is weird there's a little
bit of a war in comedy on
self-deprecation like you're not allowed
to Hate Yourself anymore and I would
like to firmly push back against that I
am old enough to be grandfathered in I
didn't get to I didn't get Renee Brown
on my Instagram when I was 15. I feel
like I'm allowed to hate myself but
there's this kind of thing now where
it's like you're not allowed to
self-deprecate
um you're misunderstanding why people
get into comedy in the first place yeah
totally and it's like you know if I'm
bombing at a show and we can all 40 of
us whoever come somewhere oh see this is
we'll see this
see this is that is the one kind of
self-deprecation I would bully you about
well right because I'm lying but yeah if
I'm bombing we're all sitting there in
silence I'm gonna talk about you know
what I mean it's like I'm cool with like
that if when it's like self-deprecation
that's like obvious yeah I mean well or
it's more like stuff that's like
if you dare to say something that
wouldn't fall under the umbrella of like
body positive you know about being like
ah because I have like kimono arms like
if I do like if I or something and then
people like you're not allowed to bully
yourself you're setting a bad example
and you're not a part of the body
positivity movement you don't get to
March anymore oh I'm in the bot I'm in
the body disgusting I'm I'm in this my
whole thing thank you so much I think I
am the body positivity godspeed y'all I
respect my bodies are disgusting whether
they're big or small or tall or short or
old or young they're fucking gross and
like I'm really glad that you feel good
about yours but I feel horrible about
mine I'm dehydrated I smell bad I look
like shit and I'm allowed to live and
I'm allowed to stand in that truth
I think you're so pretty oh my God thank
you
um what do you watch like what is your
it seems like not a lot like what do you
watch if you're just chilling at home
I'm a I'm addicted to Real Housewives it
is my I love to look at their beautiful
faces here's the deal with real
housewives I believe that it is MMA for
women
well it it is a loving lights on my
girls it is body horror because I've
been watching these women I know them
they are my friends I've been watching
some of these women for 12 years and to
see what has happened to see their faces
be it it's like to know every Contour of
Luanne de lesseps phase yeah but see the
ways in which it's either preserved or
Matt you know it's like it's and they're
so be and it's it's it's my ASMR to like
look at their lip gloss and their nice
fabrics and yeah it's I'm just upset am
I making sense you're making so much
sense because I am it's a porn in a way
I mean yes I have a hard time watching
it because I feel like I'm I have so
much to catch up on yeah and when I I
hosted the um when I did that week for
um in New York when Wendy Williams was
out I there was I had to watch so much
Real Housewives I had to be so caught up
oh my God you hosted for one day yeah
and I I know Wendy Williams we stand and
um so I just I I have so much catching
up to do yeah and I have so many
questions and Casey Wilson's a friend so
I'll be watching it now but Casey I need
like a background and she's like the the
recap is so deep like you just have you
feel emotionally overwhelmed I feel
emotionally overwhelmed I also feel like
um
I would be great at it
here's the thing I
I also get a little uncomfortable when I
feel like some of them are inebriated
oh see this is this is porn to me okay
so who's your favorite housewife because
I feel like hold on I feel like I have a
couple questions that I feel like help
us understand people in a very
fundamental level if someone tells me
their favorite Girl Scout cookie I know
everything I need to know Samoa of
course I mean duh okay good mine too
thank God oh my God if you had said
shortbread you could have gone some
weird angle like Nutter butt or like
fucking insane I don't know you were
very loved as a child you might as well
be I know you're like mentally stable I
like your whole your take about having
love in the home is actually makes you
weird yeah
because you just like get to be like
authentically yourself and you're just
yeah I don't it's it was odd to me you
make like really intense eye contact
that's so true wow and then um let's see
okay your favorite uh housewife
the audience is going to come away with
an understanding of you that even Karen
Huger
Potomac okay I don't know her she is
like why is she your favorite she is
like a count for pound most entertaining
yeah she's she's outrageous I just like
like she's just an outrageous John
Waters character I love a human being
love it love it I got in a fight with
Nanny Lakes once well she got mad at me
how about that what would you do I I had
the audacity to well we were hosting
like a New Year's Eve thing or something
and I here's the thing if you're gonna
work with a housewife on something watch
their work and know what you're signing
off for I did not know that she is um uh
not doesn't fuck around and I like made
a joke about her Giant Orange mint coat
and I will regret it for the rest of my
life that's what you get for being
hilarious
um who is your uh new favorite housewife
like a new one are you like Salt Lake
City
I don't know
am I such an amateur
crime Cinema
that's emotional crime
I love them all okay if you're not
watching Real Housewives you're watching
no
right now I want to watch all the
poltergeists okay I have a plan to watch
too because I just rewatched one I
haven't seen two and I haven't seen
three here's the thing about watching
movies like that now it's kind of
amazing on so many levels like if it
still scares you cool but also like all
the movies that scared the shit out of
me when I was a kid I look at them now
and I'm like I can see someone's hand
yeah right making the ghost puppet like
watching Poltergeist now I bet would be
like scary but also wonky because I'm
like addicted to practical effects so
like
and I make my own and they're shitty on
purpose
and So like
um like I'll make pimples out of like
um
uh bubble wrap great I inject all the
bubbles with like Vaseline and stuff
like that love it so like that's like
the best part is like watching Wizard of
Oz as a kid and being like fully like
it's so tactile and practical that
you're like I can feel it like I know
that horse was spray painted like I can
tell I'm just a kid but I know that's
too dry but it makes it more real
because it's like not in the uncanny
valley of like yes it doesn't yes it
doesn't have this like surreal nature
you're like I know these are grown men
in makeup yes and that's kind of what's
fun about it you could touch it you know
what it feels like you can feel it the
AstroTurf of Munchkin land like you know
what that feels like you could touch it
and it's more real as opposed to like
all this fucking CGI shit you know
that's like too smooth to be real that's
interesting you kind of like the
schlockiness of it
have you seen the movie that Joan Rivers
and Melissa Rivers made after Jones
husband committed suicide no you haven't
I they made it like three weeks after
they I can't this is watch something
that's gonna make me cry
when's last time you cry
it's so easy to make me really oh my God
oh my God
guess what like
you'll just a a dog that's too cute a
person that's too nice uh well you're in
Hollywood you don't have to worry about
it
like
yeah it's so easy to make me cry that's
interesting anything anytime anyone
doing something any anything of anyone
doing anything nice so they think about
any movie any TV show September 14th
you're in Los Angeles where are you
gonna be
Zebulon nice uh San Francisco September
15th
couldn't tell you Sarah pretty Club look
at this Brooklyn New York April 29th
happened Philadelphia Cleveland Chicago
homecoming we're in Chicago sleeping
Village sick rock and roll Milwaukee
Washington DC oh what please buy tickets
to Washington DC I'm kind of from there
I am where in DC are you playing the
Kennedy Center but like in the basement
I've been around you guys she's at the
fucking Kennedy Center oh it's kind of
like an office in the basement it's yeah
people are not buying them
I'll be wearing the Blue Dress On soon
um do not bring a black light Washington
DC June 25th Portland Oregon Seattle
Houston Austin what this is a very fun
schedule ah there's more go see Sarah I
don't know where you'd find out I guess
you would just have to Google her her
website is google.com just figure it out
if you love me you'll figure it out yeah
but yeah you really you're really
testing your fans well the people who
show up are the ones who want to buy my
farts in a jar it's half stand-up show
half scavenger hunt if you can find her
um you probably want to kill her
um and put her eyeballs in a
um all right I love you guys um I'm
starting to get low blood sugar and be
weird so
um uh you know what to do don't write
elephants bye
[Music]
my bed
[Applause]